L'océan abrite dans ses profondeurs,
des animaux mystérieux.
Parmi eux une créature que l'on
ne connaît essentiellement,
que par des cadavres.
Le serpent de mer.
Ces échouage ont permis aux scientifiques
d'étudier l'étrange anatomie,
de ce poisson osseux,
le plus long du monde.
Sa tête couronnée d'un toupet de rayon,
lui a valu le nom
de roi des harengs,
ou plus couramment Régalec.
Mais faute d'avoir pu l'observer vivant,
on ignorait presque tout de sa biologie.
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Au large de nos rivages,
une première mondiale.
Une expérience scientifique inédite,
va accidentellement permettre
à des plongeurs chevronnés,
d'observer, d'étudier,
et de révéler
les mœurs extraordinaires,
de cette créature singulière.
Jusqu'au début du XIXᵉ siècle,
le serpent de mer appartenait
aux monstres marins.
Des créatures légendaires qui
hantaient l'imaginaire des hommes,
et les zones d'ombre des cartes marines.
Son aspect étonnant, sa taille,
sa rareté et ses couleurs,
ont suscité chez les marins
et les pêcheurs,
des histoires, des superstitions.
On l'aurait vu s'attaquer au navire,
on l'affubler même de redoutables dents,
qui le faisaient ressembler
à un reptile marin.
Au XIXᵉ siècle, ses dents allaient
progressivement disparaître,
grâce aux descriptions des premiers naturalistes.
Ils le classaient définitivement,
parmi les poissons.
Pourtant,
leurs observations sont rares,
imprévisibles et dispersées.
Depuis deux siècles, on recense
moins de 250 échouages de Régalec,
agonisants, morts ou atrophiés,
sur les côtes tempérées
du monde entier.
Le plus long jamais recensé,
mesurait onze mètres.
Récemment, par un incroyable
concours de circonstances,
ce poisson géant aurait
été observé bien vivant,
en mer Méditerranée.
Au sud de la France,
l'insouciante Côte d'Azur.
Ses Yachts, ses citadelles,
et ces plages de sable fin.
Plus de 12 millions de baigneurs
goutent chaque année,
au plaisir des eaux chaudes
de sa mince frange littorale.
Mais qui pourrait croire,
que la mise en place d'un étrange
dispositif scientifique,
au large de ses plages,
ferait resurgir des monstres marins ?
C'est pourtant la conséquence
indirecte d'une expérience insolite.
Au cœur de l'été 2000,
l'Observatoire océanographique
de Villefranche-sur-Mer,
en collaboration avec les plus grands
organismes internationaux de recherche spatiale,
entreprend de déployer,
à 60 km au large de Nice,
une bouée océanographique
appelée la Boussole.
Son but semble plus poétique
que scientifique.
Elle est destinée à acquérir les données
in situ de la couleur de l'eau,
et les transmettre.
Ces données vont permettre de calibrer
les satellites qui observent les océans.
La couleur de l'eau, qui varie
selon les saisons et les lieux,
est un bon indicateur
de la présence de plancton.
Ainsi, au printemps,
les algues microscopiques
et leurs prédateurs abondent.
On parle de bloom planctoniques.
La chlorophylle des algues donne
une couleur verte à l'eau de mer.
Ici commence la vaste chaîne
alimentaire des océans.
Pour connaître l'évolution
de la Méditerranée,
les observations de la bouée
et de la boussole,
doivent être continues,
sur plusieurs années.
Au cœur de ce dispositif technique,
un biologiste passionné.
Je suis David Luquet.
Je suis plongeur scientifique.
Je travaille à l'Observatoire
océanologique de Villefranche-sur-Mer,
et je suis responsable de l'entretien
de la bouée boussole.
Avec des outils aussi
rudimentaires qu'efficace,
il n'intervient que dans
les premiers mètres,
sur la structure immergée de la bouée.
Au-delà, il passe le relais à d'autres
spécialistes des travaux sous-marins.
Pour être au cœur de la production
de plancton,
les scientifiques ont décidé d'arrimer
la bouée au milieu d'un courant giratoire,
appelé courant liguro-provençal.
Problème,
à cet endroit, la profondeur
atteint 2500 mètres.
Un lourd mouillage surmonté
de 2,5km de câble en kevlar,
doit donc être déposé.
Perdu dans l'immensité de l'océan,
la bouée, sa structure et sa chaîne,
servent de point de repère aux passagers,
du courant liguro-provençal.
Les roof des épaves.
Les sérioles.
Les poissons-pilotes.
Et enfin les cerniers.
Ces poissons vivent
dans la zone photique,
les couches d'eau de faible profondeur,
suffisamment exposées à la lumière
pour que la photosynthèse soit possible.
Tropisme du cône d'ombre de la bouée,
ils y trouvent à la fois
gîte et couverts.
La plupart navigue à vue.
Certains viennent se nourrir des algues
qui poussent sur la structure,
et les plus petits sont dévorés
par les plus grands.
D'autres, enfin,
comme les poissons-pilotes,
se sont spécialisés
dans une activité particulière.
La collecte des miettes des repas,
ou des parasites des grands prédateurs,
qui visitent la bouée.
Y compris, le plus redouté.
Le grand requin blanc.
Le squale a été observé uniquement
au printemps près de la surface.
Décrivant des vastes cercles
concentriques, autour de la boussole.
Une petite population estimée
à seulement 350 Requins blancs,
survit en Méditerranée.
Que viennent-ils chercher ici ?
À 60 km des plages ?
Certainement d'autres
visiteurs de la bouée,
comme les thons.
Mais on ne l'a jamais vu s'y nourrir.
Et ses séjours sont rares et brefs.
Chaque mois, David s'attend
à des rencontres imprévues,
quand il vient entretenir la bouée.
Sa mission : nettoyer des capteurs
optiques sous-marins.
Le matériel est toujours aussi
rudimentaire mais efficace.
Solidement arrimé au plongeur pour
ne pas tomber 2500 mètres plus bas.
Des plongées à risques.
David est seul,
au dessus du grand bleu,
sans protection.
En moins d'un mois,
les colonisations par les algues
et les mollusques,
rendent totalement inopérants les
20 instruments de mesure de la bouée.
À chaque capteur, sa brosse.
Le nettoyage crée
des vibrations, des sons,
émis dans toutes les directions.
Des ondes qui sont perçues par
les animaux qui gravitent près de la bouée.
Elles attisent leur curiosité.
Hors ces sons se propage le long de
la chaîne jusque dans les profondeurs.
Les poissons ne connaissent pas l'homme,
donc ils ne le craignent pas.
Leur curiosité est réciproque.
David sous la bouée,
c'est l'homme face à l'inconnu.
Un jour, au mois d'avril,
lors du bloom planctonique,
l'eau était vraiment très trouble.
Je venais de finir mon travail,
et je suis descendue inspecter le bas
de la bouée au niveau du câble en kevlar.
Et là...
J'ai vu un très long ruban argenté
qui remontait des profondeurs.
Le roi des harengs.
L'ambassadeur des Ténèbres en visite,
à la frontière de notre monde.
Pour la première fois au monde,
un plongeur nage
avec le poisson mythique.
David découvre qu'il nage verticalement
et non horizontalement,
comme les serpents de mer
des gravures anciennes.
Étrange, la queue
de l'animal est sectionné.
Est-ce dû à une rencontre
avec le requin blanc ?
Pour y répondre, il faut pouvoir
observer de près les marques de morsure.
Malheureusement, les bulles
de David semblent effrayer l'animal.
Cette rencontre accidentelle est
trop brève pour examiner la blessure.
Après quelques minutes,
le poisson couronné,
retourne dans la zone aphotique,
ces profondeurs où pénètrent
aussi peu de lumière,
que la photosynthèse
n'est plus possible.
Pour anticiper d'autres rencontres,
il faut déjà comprendre
comment le régalec,
parvient à détecter
la bouée dans la pénombre,
et l'immensité du courant
liguro-provençal.
Par chance pour David,
à des milliers de km de la bouée,
une série d'événements extraordinaires
allait permettre aux scientifiques,
de révéler des facettes méconnues
de la biologie du poisson mythique.
Au Japon, le régalec est connu sous
l'étrange nom de Ryugu no Tsukai.
Comprenez, le messager
du Palais des dieux.
En quelques mois d'hiver 2014,
plus d'une douzaine de régalec
de toutes tailles,
ont été déposées
par les courants marins,
sur les rivages du sud du Japon.
Selon la mythologie Japonaise,
les messagers du Palais des Dieux,
annonceraient par leurs échouages,
l'imminence d'un tremblement de terre.
Ces apparitions impromptues,
n'ont jamais pu être corrélées
avec l'activité sismique de la région.
Mais ont offert au docteur Tyson Roberts,
le spécialiste mondial du Régalec,
une opportunité inespérée,
pour mener une étude systématique
sur des animaux frais.
Ceci est un régalec.
Il mesure huit mètres.
C'est le plus long poisson
osseux du monde,
avec peut être le plus petit cerveau
du monde relativement à sa taille.
Pour le prouver, il va utiliser
les derniers cri de la technologie,
dans une clinique vétérinaire.
Les Japonais ont mis à sa disposition un
appareil d'imagerie par résonance magnétique,
ou IRM qui permet d'obtenir des images,
en deux ou trois dimensions
d'un corps vivant.
Appliqué sur une tête de régalec, l'IRM
vétérinaire conçu pour des petits animaux,
permet de réaliser des images plus
fines qu'avec un IRM humain.
Indispensable pour isoler le cerveau
du régalec et ses ramifications.
J'aimerais en apprendre davantage sur
son cerveau et son système endocrinien,
c'est à dire, comme chez l'homme,
toutes les glandes,
qui sécrètent des hormones
dans le système circulatoire.
Pour la première fois au monde,
nous allons tenter une description,
exhaustive de l'anatomie du régalec.
Les images en IRM confirment
l'hypothèse initiale.
Ce cerveau ne mesure
environ que deux cm,
c'est-à-dire la moitié
de la taille de son œil.
Un petit pois dans la tête.
Voici la taille du cerveau d'un régalec.
Paradoxalement, il contrôle
la plus longue moelle épinière,
et le plus long tube digestif
connu chez un poisson.
Mieux, les rayons X d'un scanner
du vétérinaire,
vont permettre de pénétrer
dans les détails,
des structures osseuses
du crâne du Régalec,
et de résoudre une énigme tenace.
Comment le régalec se repère t-il
dans le noir des abysses ?
La plupart des poissons utilisent parfois
la vue, un peu les sons, mais surtout les odeurs.
Mais chez le Régalec,
ce sens paraissait absent.
J'ai examiné quelque chose
comme 35 spécimens de régalec,
et je n'ai jamais vu de narines,
c'est-à-dire la terminaison
du système olfactif.
Personne n'a jamais évoqué
l'existence de narines,
ou d'organes olfactifs chez le Régalec.
Mais avec ce grand spécimen,
j'ai trouvé les narines.
Elles ne sont ni à l'extérieur
ni sur le côté de la tête.
Elles sont à la pointe de son museau
dans la cavité buccale,
et peuvent s'ouvrir
sur leurs parties antérieures.
Ses narines sont donc situées
à l'intérieur de sa gueule.
Aussi pour repérer des odeurs
dans la pénombre,
le Régalec doit garder
ses mâchoires entrouvertes,
et pomper l'eau en permanence.
En fait, il est probable
que ces deux organes olfactifs,
ces petites fentes coniques,
puissent se fermer.
Si bien qu'en les ouvrant
et les fermant,
l'animal obtienne une indication
sur l'origine des odeurs.
La conséquence est surprenante.
Le régalec est capable de remonter la piste
des odeurs dans l'immensité de l'océan,
simplement en effectuant des pirouettes.
Si vous sentez une effluve, mais
vous ne savez pas d'où elle vient,
vous faites face à une direction donnée.
Si cette effluve est légère,
vous fermez vos narines,
et vous faites face à une autre direction.
Vous ouvrez ensuite vos narines
et vous tournez votre tête.
Si l'odeur est plus forte,
vous êtes sur la bonne voie.
Vous remontez ainsi
la piste des odeurs,
en ouvrant et fermant vos narines.
C'est une véritable partie
de jeu sous-marine.
Quand ses yeux ne voient
qu'un bleu infini,
le régalec et son petit cerveau
peuvent localiser, rejoindre,
et rester autour de la boussole,
grâce à une éffluve.
Serait-ce l'odeur de la bouée ?
Celle d'une source de nourriture ?
Ou d'un tout autre parfum,
émis par une créature des profondeurs ?
Pour en avoir le cœur net,
il faut être capable de plonger
jusqu'à la limite de la zone photique.
là où la lumière s'arrête.
David Luquet, fait appel à un spécialiste
des plongées profondes en mer Méditerranée,
le caméraman italien Roberto Rinaldi.
J'ai vraiment envie
de rencontrer le régalec.
mais dès qu'on est partis,
je commençais à me sentir,
un peu perdu dans l'immensité de la mer.
On va être des petits points
minuscules dans le bleu,
et ça va être vraiment difficile
de rencontrer ce poisson.
Pour le débusquer et l'approcher,
il envisage d'utiliser
un appareil respiratoire,
qui allie performance et discrétion.
Le recycleur.
Aujourd'hui grâce au recycleur on peut
plonger profond et longtemps.
On va récupérer le mélange
gazeux qu'on respire.
Quand on filme, on ne fait
pas de bulles avec le recycleur.
Les poissons sont habitués
à tout sauf aux bulles.
Avec le recycleur, on a beaucoup
plus de temps et de chance,
pour approcher les régalecs.
En chemin vers la boussole,
David suggère de plonger
sous une autre bouée voisine,
également immergée
par 2500 mètres de fond.
Une bouée météorologique
simplement nommée "Côte d'Azur".
Un outil sophistiqué de mesure des
températures de houle et de vent,
afin d'alimenter en données
les centres de prévision.
Sous ses jupes métalliques,
cette bâtisse gémissante,
semble attirer davantage les poissons
du large que la boussole.
C'est grincements portes
à plusieurs centaines de mètres,
dans toutes les directions.
Rien n'est laissé au hasard.
Finies les brèves plongées
mensuelles à la boussole.
Désormais, David et Roberto
séjournent plusieurs journées d'affilée,
près de la bouée météo
en plongeant à tout moment.
À commencer par l'aube.
Ils ont synchronisé leur venue avec le pic
printanier de production de plancton,
donc de protéines animales.
Ainsi, si le régalec est bien attiré
par une source de nourriture odorante,
ou par les sons de la bouée,
ils augmentent
leurs chances de rencontre.
En surface des Vellèles.
Ce ne sont pas des méduses,
mais des colonies de polypes,
qui dérivent au gré
des vents et des courants.
Pour sa première plongée, Roberto
s'immerge, non pas avec une caméra,
mais avec une canne surmontée
d'une éponge à récurer.
Elle est destinée à prélever
du mucus sur la peau du régalec.
afin d'effectuer
des analyses génétiques.
David dans les premiers mètres
avec sa bouteille d'air,
Roberto en profondeur en recycleur.
Ainsi s'organise la quête
méthodique du serpent argenté.
Ces créatures serpentiformes,
ne sont pas des régalaient,
ni des méduses,
mais des salpes.
Des animaux filtreurs
de bactéries et de phytoplancton,
qui développent leur chaîne de semblable
par reproduction hermaphrodites.
Par moins 40 mètres,
à la limite des eaux chaudes et froides,
là où leur nourriture abonde,
ils se clonent et pullulent.
C'est dans cette soupe organique,
que Roberto a fait la rencontre,
de tous les records.
Un géant de cinq mètres.
Le plus grand régalec
jamais observé vivant,
dans son environnement.
Le plus long poisson
osseux jamais recensé,
en mer Méditerranée.
Sa queue n'est pas coupée,
comme celle de l'animal
observé par David.
Une chance inespérée à saisir
pour le connaître,
avant qu'il ne reparte.
Pour pouvoir prélever
un échantillon de mucus,
Roberto et son recycleur,
devront miser sur leur discrétion.
Et gager sur la curiosité du poisson.
Curiosité du poisson pour l'homme,
et pour la bouée.
Curieusement, la peau lisse
et sans écailles du régalec,
semble insensible à ce contact rugueux.
À tout contact.
Mais quand sa curiosité est rassasiée,
le géant repart dans les profondeurs.
Imbibé de son précieux mucus,
le grattoir est envoyé
dans l'alcool pour analyse,
à l'Université de Bretagne occidentale.
Eléonore Méheut tente d'extraire
l'ADN du géant,
et de le comparer aux rares prélèvements
en provenance d'animaux échoués.
En fait, il y a très peu de données
génétiques qui sont disponibles,
dans la littérature
concernant cette espèce.
Clairement, on a pas mal de choses
à apprendre d'une étude génétique,
qui serait basée sur des spécimens
prélevés dans leur milieu naturel.
Après pas mal de mises
au point technique,
on a pu extraire de l'ADN des échantillons
de mucus que l'on a analysés.
On a trouvé 10% de variations,
entre les différents individus
de la même espèce.
C'est extrêmement fort pour
la séquence ADN que l'on détermine.
Il semble qu'y aurait
2 groupes de régalec,
et il se trouve que notre échantillon
est proche d'un des 2 groupes.
Ces données semblent conformes
aux tests du Dr Tyson Roberts,
qui soutient qu'il n'y a pas une
mais deux espèces de régalec.
En Méditerranée,
le régalec appartiendraient
à l'espèce Regalecus glesne.
Présente dans les eaux
tempérées du monde entier.
Dans les eaux chaudes
de l'océan Pacifique,
c'est l'espèce Regalecus russelii
qui dominerait.
Les différences morphologiques entre
les deux Roi des harengs, sont subtil.
Sur sa couronne, glesne possède
entre 4 et 7 crêtes de plus,
que russelii.
Le laboratoire breton s'intéresse
moins à ces débats morphologiques,
qu'à une question plus pressante.
De quoi se nourrit le régalec
en mer Méditerranée ?
On est parti sur
des études de lipidique,
à défaut de pouvoir étudier
le contenu de l'estomac d'un prédateur,
on s'attache à étudier ce qu'on
appelle les lipides de réserve,
qui portent en elles
la trace des lipides des proies.
Malheureusement, les études
que l'on a effectuées sur le mucus,
ne nous ont pas donné
de résultats réellement satisfaisants.
Ce dont on aurait besoin,
c'est de travailler sur
des vrais tissus de régalec.
Une mission qui semble impossible.
Prélever des bouts
de nageoires non pas sur un,
mais sur plusieurs régalecs vivants.
Autre difficulté,
Même au pic du bloom planctoniques,
les rencontres restent aléatoires.
Quand la météo le permet, les plongeurs
effectuent plusieurs plongées par jour,
sur l'une ou l'autre des bouées
à différentes saisons.
Les statistiques de David
sont éloquentes.
Sur plus de 120 plongées à la boussole,
il n'a vu que deux fois un régalec.
La chance n'existe pas.
Les rencontres se préparent,
se provoquent,
et se désirent.
Un régalec a répondu
à l'appel de la bouée,
et il n'est pas seul.
Dans l'immensité de l'océan,
comment ces poissons du large peuvent-ils
se retrouver ici, au même moment ?
Probablement grâce à leur odorat.
Encore faut-il qu'ils émettent une substance
qui voyage sur de longues distances,
au gré des courants.
Mais quelle serait cette substance ?
Une phéromone, c'est-à-dire un produit
chimique produit par un régalec,
pour attirer un autre régalec.
Ainsi le régalec est capable
d'envoyer un message codé,
uniquement détectable
par d'autres régalec,
sur de très longues distances.
Et quand ils sont proches,
les régalec communiqueraient
par le langage du corps.
À quoi lui servent sa crête
et ses grandes nageoires pelviennes ?
À l'évidence, elles ressemblent
à un dispositif de signalisation,
propre au régalec.
Les plongeurs vont
confirmer son hypothèse.
Pour être vu par ses congénères,
le poisson à la peau miroir,
adopte une posture étonnante,
La croix.
Ces postures statiques,
devraient permettre à David
de l'approcher pour prélever des tissus.
Encore faut-il pouvoir
nager à son rythme.
Et le contraindre à rester
près de la surface.
Pas si simple.
Et avec sa petite nageoire qui vibre,
il ne bouge pas, il vibre sans arrêt.
Il est capable d'aller très vite.
On pourrait l'appeler poisson piège parce
qu'en fait, il a une attitude méchante.
mais il ne fait rien,
il ne fait pas de mouvements.
Et est ce que pour un poisson,
La verticalité,
ça représente quelque chose,
comme pour nous ?
Pour les plongeurs, descendre est aisé,
mais ils risquent des accidents de
décompression en remontant trop rapidement.
Reste une solution.
Passer en dessous du régalec.
Au fil des mois, David et Roberto,
multiplient les plongées
et les prélèvements de nageoires.
À chaque retour au port,
ils envoient les échantillons
au laboratoire brestois.
Or, à l'image du premier régalec
rencontré par David,
la plupart présentent un corps tronqué.
Le requin blanc figure naturellement
parmi la liste des suspects.
Cette fois, les plongeurs ont eu l'occasion
d'observer en détail de multiples cicatrices.
Le docteur Tyson Roberts emet
une toute autre hypothèse.
Grâce notamment aux multiples
animaux échoués au Japon.
Les régalec effectuent fréquemment
une série d'autotomie.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça signifie que les régalec
s'amputent eux-mêmes.
C'est comme un lézard quand
il se coupe la queue,
à la différence près qu'un lézard
ne se coupe la queue qu'à un endroit,
le régalec, lui, peut se couper la partie
postérieure à l'anus à répétition,
à commencer par la nageoire caudale,
et progressivement se couper
des morceaux supplémentaires,
des longs, des courts,
de toutes les tailles.
Et il peut faire ça d'un coup
jusqu'à l'anus qui est ici.
Et on peut trouver des régalec
où il ne reste que ça.
À la différence du lézard,
le régalec n'abandonnerait pas
sa queue pour échapper à un prédateur,
mais pour d'autres raisons étonnantes.
L'autotomie,
la sévérité de l'autotomie,
le nombre de fois qu'elle est pratiquée
dépend vraiment d'un individu à l'autre.
C'est une question d'économie d'énergie.
Le régalec décide cette métamorphose
vers un corps où il ne conserve,
que ses gonades et ses organes vitaux.
Mais c'est très rare chez les poissons.
À ce jour, c'est le seul
poisson connu qui pratique ça.
Pour pouvoir prouver cette
hypothèse révolutionnaire,
il faudrait observer
cette mutilation volontaire,
ou retrouver des morceaux de corps
de régalec au fond des océans,
autant chercher des arêtes
dans la vase des abysses.
Mais près du village de Macerata,
sur la côte est de l'Italie,
la chance a souri à un géologue.
Dans une carrière abandonnée,
le professeur Patrizio Bonzi,
vient d'excaver un curieux fossile
déposé au fond de la mer Adriatique,
il y a environ 2 millions d'années,
puis remonté par
un glissement de terrain.
Ça c'est l'unique exemplaire connu
au monde de régalec fossiles.
Il s'agit de la partie
postérieure du corps.
Elle est repliée sur elle-même,
mais nous pouvons l'ouvrir.
Le principe de l'autotomie,
a donc été gravée dans d'anciens
sédiments marins,
pour l'éternité.
D'autres indices, notamment
de son comportement alimentaire,
pourraient être apportés
par les études lipidiques,
grâce aux nageoires collectées
par David et Roberto.
Encore faut-il identifier maintenant
les proies du régalec,
et donc leur signature lipidique.
Là on va poser deux pièges,
un qui va être en surface pour
attraper des larves de poisson
et un autre un peu plus profond
pour attraper des petits crustacés,
comme des copépodes.
Comme un phare sous-marin,
la lumière du piège pique la curiosité
du petit peuple des ténèbres.
Certains gravitent autour du filet.
D'autres viennent y trouver refuge.
De jour, les pêches sont maigres.
Mais quand le piège
est immergé toute une nuit,
les collectes matinales
réservent bien des surprises.
Ces petites crevettes ne sont
autres que du krill.
Cette espèce, présente en abondance
dans le nord de l'Atlantique,
ferait briller
ces organes bioluminescents,
dans la zone aphotique de Méditerranée.
Mieux, après analyse des échantillons
à l'Université de Bretagne occidentale,
la signature lipidique de ce krill,
se retrouve dans la chair du régalec.
Or la nuit, le krill effectue
des migrations verticales,
pour s'approcher de la surface
et s'y nourrire plancton.
Ainsi, il évite les chasseurs diurnes,
comme la plupart des poissons
qui gravitent autour des bouées.
Mais dans son sillage,
il entraîne tous ces prédateurs.
Dont la vue est adaptée
au très faible lumières.
Parmi eux, les régalecs.
Pour tenter d'observer leur festin,
les aquanautes doivent
oser des plongées de nuit.
Au large, en recycleur,
sans aucun repère,
et au dessus de 2500 mètres
d'apesanteur.
Il faut vraiment être attentif.
On est dans le noir complet.
Et on n'a pas
de possibilité de s'orienter.
D'étranges visiteurs gélatineux
font leur apparition,
dans le noir infini.
Tel un super organisme,
ces aliens des profondeurs remontent
ensemble chaque nuit.
Pour un festin hors norme.
C'est la plus grande migration
de biomasse au monde.
Dans leur piège urticant,
du krill, signe prometteur.
Mais où sont passés les poissons ?
Les résidents du jour ?
Ils semblent craindre de grands
prédateurs invisibles.
Et se regroupe.
Idem face aux menaces fantômes,
David et Roberto se rapprochent.
Pour mieux surveiller
dans toutes les directions.
Un poisson lune.
Fausse alerte.
Plonger la nuit au large, c'est comme un
enfant qui rentre dans un magasin de jouets,
avec les faisceaux de lumière, on va
révéler des couleurs magnifiques,
on ne voient pas le jour. On sait
qu'il y a beaucoup de jouets partout.
On en voit très peu, mais c'est suffisant
pour être émerveillé par ce qu'on voit.
Le poisson roi.
Dans ses habits de lumière.
Seuls les éclairages sous marins,
révèlent ses couleurs exubérantes
et sa peau miroir.
À quoi lui servent-elles
dans le noir absolu ?
À refléter les lumières du krill
pour mieux s'immiscer parmi ses proies.
Mystère.
Une énigme d'autant plus insoluble,
que le poisson ignore le krill.
Pourtant, il détend sa bouche,
comme pour attraper
des proies invisibles.
Les éclairages perturberait
donc son festin ?
À y regarder de plus près, de minuscules
visiteurs semblent aller et venir,
à leur gré dans la gueule du régalec.
Des parasites.
Ceux-ci sont des parasites externes,
qui ne séjournent pas en permanence
dans le corps du Régalec.
Les parasites internes, eux,
permettent de placer le régalec dans
la chaîne alimentaire, en particulier,
de connaître ses prédateurs.
C'est du moins l'avis
de doctorantes américaines,
spécialisée dans l'étude
des parasites de poissons.
À l'université de Santa Barbara
en Californie,
ce sont des contenus stomacaux
de régalecs échoués qui ont permis,
à Sarah Weinstein et Anna Garcia,
de faire d'étonnantes découvertes.
Les parasites offrent un bel
aperçu de la vie du régalec,
des informations qu'on ne
pourrait pas avoir autrement,
car ces parasites ont des cycles
complexes en grandissant,
à travers plusieurs hôtes.
Par exemple, on a trouvé au moins
trois espèces de nématodes.
Ça c'est vraiment intéressant.
Car l'une d'entre elles ressemble
beaucoup à une espèce qui utilise,
les mammifères marins
comme leur dernier hôte.
Après analyse approfondie,
l'Université de Santa Barbara a confirmé
que la présence de nématodes juvéniles,
dans les viscères de Régalec,
apporterait la preuve que ce poisson,
est la proie de prédateurs
des profondeurs.
Comme les cachalots.
En effet, ces grands cétacés sont connus,
pour être les hôtes
de la même espèce de nématodes,
au stade adulte.
Les nématodes qui vivent
dans la chair du régalec,
arrive avec les proies
qu'il consomme comme le krill.
Or le krill lui apporterait également
ces bactéries bioluminescentes.
Mais à ce jour, aucun organe bioluminescent
n'a été trouvé sur le régalec.
Ils sont en effet difficilement
détectables sur des poissons morts.
Les lumières émises par la plupart
des poissons bioluminescents,
sont si faibles qu'on ne peut
les détecter à l'oeil nu.
C'est le cas chez le Régalec.
Aussi, David et Roberto suggèrent
de remplacer les lampes ordinaires,
par des lampes ultraviolette.
En abrégé uv, qui révèle la
fluorescence des êtres vivants.
Notamment les leurres lumineux
des mangeurs de krill.
En identifiant les zones fluorescentes,
on isole les organes
dont la bioluminescence,
pourrait être révélée par une analyse
chimique et microscopique.
Malheureusement, la portée
de ces lampes UV dans l'eau,
est bien moindre que celle
des lampes ordinaires,
qui annulent leur effet.
L'exercice est à la fois
dangereux et difficile.
David va devoir repérer le régalec
grâce aux lumières blanches,
puis les éteindre
et laisser Roberto et ses uv,
l'approcher de très près.
Pari osé.
Pari gagné !
Les lampes UV révèlent 2 organes
fluorescents sur le crâne du régalec,
l'un sous le menton,
l'autre sur le front.
Ces organes pourraient
être bioluminescents,
mais seuls un examen approfondi
sur des poissons vivants ou agonisants,
pourrait le confirmer.
Tels des pièges lumineux miniatures,
ils permettraient aux régalec,
de leurrer ses proies.
Sa beauté peut aussi être fatale,
pour les plongeurs.
Un moment donné, je me suis rendu compte
que sa crête montait vers le haut.
Et j'ai réalisé qu'on en était
en train de descendre à toute vitesse.
Quand j'ai regardé la montre,
on était à 71 mètres.
C'est un piège de ce petit poisson.
Il m'a amené chez lui, dans son abysse.
Le serpent de mer n'est
plus la créature mythique,
qui dévorait les navires.
Seul son envoûtante beauté
peut être fatale.
Au plongeur de l'occulter,
pour mieux dire
le monde du poisson roi.
Un animal rare.
Inoffensif.
Et féérique.